In this video we bring you the breaking news
about House of the Dragon.
HBO just announced on Game of Thrones official
twitter account
that Game of Thrones prequel series, House
of the Dragon, casted major roles and picked
season 1 directors. We are talking about the
main characters that are going to play a major
role in this prequel such as Daemon and Rhaenyra
Targaryen and Alicent Hightower.
Real quick before we go into it, I know and
understand that some of you might not be too
happy with the casting for House of the Dragon,
but let me tell you this: While the lead cast
is announced and confirmed, it's definitely
not final yet. You see, Game of Thrones prequel
starts filming in about 40 days, and during
the filming, there might be some changes if
they don't prove to be the best choice.
For example, during the first filming of Game
of Thrones, several actors, major and minor
were replaced.
Tamzin Merchant originally played Daenerys
Targaryen, but she was replaced by Emilia
Clarke.
Jennifer Ehle originally played Catelyn Stark,
but was replaced by Michelle Fairley.
In other words, if these lead actors don't
prove to be the best possible choice,
they will be replaced during the filming of
House of the Dragon.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
Thats Fire And Blood volume 1.
The yet unreleased Fire And Vlood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
Key event of the prequel will be the Dance
of the Dragon, a Targaryen civil war.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
A war of succession between Aegon II and his
half-sister Rhaenyra over their father Viserys
I's throne.
Both of them thought they belonged on the
Iron Throne. When people started declaring
for one of them or the other, their fight
divided the kingdoms in two.
Targaryens fought Targaryens, bothers fought
brothers, dragons fought dragons. By the time
it was over, thousands were dead. The conflict
would prove to be incredibly destructive for
not only House Targaryen, but large parts
of Westeros as well. In addition, it devastated
the Targaryen's dragon population, ultimately
leading to their extinction within a few decades.
Rhaenyra is one of the main characters in
the Targaryen civil war at the heart of the
show.
Emma D'Arcy is casted to play her. Casting
call described her as: “King Viserys’
chosen heir,
a dragon rider who grew up expecting to become
the first ruling Queen of Westeros.”
The official description describes her as
“the king’s first-born child, she is of
pure Valyrian blood,
and she is a dragonrider. Many would say that
Rhaenyra was born with everything…
but she was not born a man.”
Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen, cheered as the
Realm's Delight when she was young and later
called the Half-Year Queen, was the first-born
child of King Viserys I Targaryen. Rhaenyra
was King Viserys I's only living child by
his first wife, Queen Aemma of House Arryn.
At the age of eight she was made her father's
heir and grew up expecting to become the first
ruling Queen of Westeros. Rhaenyra was a dragonrider
whose mount was Syrax.
Rhaenyra had her family's Valyrian looks,
wearing her silver-gold hair in a long braid
in the manner of Queen Visenya Targaryen.
Beautiful as a child, Rhaenyra was later declared
by her uncle, Prince Daemon Targaryen, to
be the most beautiful maiden in all the Seven
Kingdoms.
Due to the lack of a male heir, Viserys designated
Rhaenyra as his successor. Therefore, Rhaenyra
was the only female Targaryen to lay claim
to the Iron Throne in her own right.
Since she was raised as the designated heir,
Rhaenyra became quite pampered and arrogant,
but also gained practical governmental experience.
After Rhaenyra's mother died, her father remarried
and had several sons by his second wife, Alicent
of House Hightower. Even so, Viserys still
publicly expected his daughter to succeed
him, and when he died, his official will even
stated so. However, Rhaenyra's younger half-brother,
Aegon, challenged her claim. He stated that
the normal inheritance laws of the Andals
(which formed the basis of the unified law
code in Westeros) called for male-preference
primogeniture, meaning that a younger son
would rightfully inherit before an older daughter.
At the time of her father's death, Rhaenyra
was on Dragonstone awaiting the birth of her
child. The greens in King's Landing ensured
that the news of the Viserys's death did not
reach her until her own supporters in the
Red Keep were dead or imprisoned and Aegon
II's coronation had already occurred.
This began a devastating civil war that tore
apart the Seven Kingdoms, known as The Dance
of the Dragons, as it was the only war in
which both sides had dragonriders.
Rhaenyra had 2 husbands and 5 sons. Her fist
husband was Laenor of House Velayrion,
son of the Sea Snake, and her second husband
was her uncle, Daemon Targaryen, the Rogue
Prince,
and there we come to the second announced
lead actor: Matt Smith will play Daemon.
George R.R. Martin revealed that Daemon is
his favorite Targaryen,
so that tells you something about the character.
HBO describes the character as the “younger
brother to King Viserys and heir to the throne.
A peerless warrior and a dragonrider, Daemon
possesses the true blood of the dragon.
But it’s said that whenever a Targaryen
is born, the gods toss a coin in the air…”
Daemon Targaryen also known as Prince of the
City, Lord Flea Bottom and the Rogue Prince
had many titles throughout his life: Prince,
Ser, Commander of the City Watch, Master of
coin, master of laws, King of the stepstones
and the narrow sea, protector of the realm.
Daemon was the most contoversial man of his
lifetime, an audacious rogue prince and adventuer
who seemed made of good and evil in equal
measure.
There was never a man so loved and so reviled,
and at a same time, as he was.
During the Dance of the Dragons, as the husband
of his niece Rhaenyra, he supported his wife's
claim, and he was considered by many the most
dangerous man in Westeros.
He was Rhaenyra's second husband, following
Ser Laenor Velaryon and she was his third
wife.
Prince Daemon was the most experienced warrior
of his time and wielded the Valyrian steel
blade Dark Sister. A dragonrider whose dragon
was Caraxes, Daemon declared himself the King
of the Stepstones and the Narrow Sea.
Daemon was a skilled warrior, described in
the histories as dashing, daring, and dangerous.
He was also ambitious, impetuous, mercurial,
amoral, reckless, and quick to take offense.
He is described as being as charming as he
was hot-tempered.
Daemon's most epic moment comes from the most
epic dragon battle: battle above the Gods
eye between two most dangerous warriors at
that time, Daemon and Aemond Targaryen and
their two dragons, which also were the strongest
of all, Vhagar and Caraxes.
Daemon challenged Aemond, waiting for thirteen
days at Harrenhal until Aemond stopped burning
the riverlands to come face him.
When Caraxes attacked Vhagar, she ripped upon
his stomach and tore one of his wings, but
then Caraxes fastened his jaws around her
throat in death grip.
These injuries forced them both to cease flying
and as they tumbled to the water below, Daemon
dueled Aemond to the death.
As he never fastened his saddle, Daemon stood
up on Caraxes and leapt at Aemond, whereupon
he drove his Dark Sister through Aemond's
eye and through his neck, just a second before
hitting the water.
The Battle Above the Gods Eye ended in the
deaths of both riders and both dragons. Daemon
was forty-nine when he died. Unlike Aemond's
body, however, Daemon's was never found. Singers
say that Daemon lived to spend the rest of
his days in secret with Nettles, but most
historians disagree.
Last, but not least, HBO also announced that
Olivia Cooke is also a lead actor,
casted to play Alicent Hightower. Alicent
Hightower is described as “the daughter
of Otto Hightower, the Hand of the King, and
the most comely woman in the Seven Kingdoms.
She was raised in the Red Keep, close to the
king and his innermost circle; she possesses
both a courtly grace and a keen political
acumen.”
Alicent Hightower was a member of House Hightower
who became the second wife to King Viserys
I Targaryen and therefore a Queen of the Targaryen
dynasty. She was the daughter of Ser Otto
Hightower, who had been Hand of the King to
Jaehaerys I, Viserys I, and later his grandson
Aegon II. She was the mother of King Aegon
II, Queen Helaena, Prince Aemond and Prince
Daeron.
Alicent Hightower was in many ways the true
leader of Aegon II's faction during the Dance
of the Dragons.
At first young Rhaenyra and Alicent got along
well, but a rift grew between them as soon
as Alicent produced her own children for Viserys
I, and clearly wanted them to succeed to the
throne instead of her. Alicent bore Viserys
I four children: Aegon II, Aemond One-Eye,
Daeron the Daring, and Helaena (who became
the sister-wife of Aegon II).
Over the years of Viserys I's reign, despite
his best efforts, a bitter rivalry grew between
Alicent and Rhaenyra at court, as well as
between their rival factions of supporters.
In 111 AC, a great tourney was held at King's
Landing on the fifth anniversary of the king’s
marriage to Queen Alicent. At the opening
feast, Alicent wore a green gown, whilst Princess
Rhaenyra dressed in Targaryen red and black.
Soon afterwards, their respective followers
started dressing in similar colors and styles
to display their political allegiance: Rhaenyra's
faction (the "Princess's followers") wore
black clothing, and Alicent's faction ("the
Queen's followers") wore green clothing .
Ultimately this inspired the nicknames for
the two factions: "the Blacks and the Greens".
Viserys I publicly and repeatedly made the
great lords of the realm swear oaths that
Rhaenyra would succeed him on the Iron Throne,
as the first Ruling Queen.
A matter of hours after Viserys I died in
his sleep, however, Alicent staged a coup
- one that she had long been planning down
to the fine details.
One night, a servant found the old king had
died in his sleep and ran to inform Queen
Alicent.
Protocol dictated that the bells would be
rung, everyone notified and a raven sent to
Dragonstone to summon the heir, Princess Rhaenyra,
for her coronation. But Alicent had other
plans. Once she saw her dead husband's body,
she sealed the room and had the servant thrown
into the Black Cells to ensure his silence.
According to Mushroom, who was away with Rhaenyra
Targaryen on Dragonstone, Alicent poisoned
Viserys's drink.
True or not, instead of announcing Viserys
I's death immediately, Alicent warned Ser
Criston Cole, now Lord Commander of the Kingsguard,
and together, they called the small council
to discuss the succession, where plans were
made to crown Alicent's son Prince Aegon,
instead of Princess Rhaenyra, who had been
Viserys's heir.
This started the Targaryen civil war which
will be the key event of the upcoming Game
of Thrones prequel, House of the Dragon. We
also know the directors for the first season.
In addition to Game of Thrones veteran Miguel
Sapochnik, who’s serving as showrunner
along with Ryan Condal, the directing team
will also include Clare Kilner, Geeta Patel
and Greg Yaitanes.
The first season is confirmed to consist of
ten episodes. House of the Dragon is coming!
Thank you so much for watching, hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did make sure to give
it a big thumbs upand I hope to see you in
the next one, peace!